have you ever found yourself speaking
English with a weird hybrid accent when
you go abroad or know someone who
doesn't sound like a native speaker of a
language even when they're fluent
this is why you have a different I sent
in a foreign language
the first reason is that sounds
different from language to language
open a textbook and one of the first
things you'll see is an alphabet
explaining for example that the p in
French is very different from the p in
English
foreign
the palm of your hand up in front of
your mouth and say Paris in English
you'll feel a little puff of air on your
hand now try the same thing again but
try to remove that puff of air and
you'll get something closer to the
French sound
[Music]
learning about letters individually
tells you very little about how they
work when they come together
for example when certain consonant
combinations are forbidden in your
native language you'll often find
yourself inserting sounds to make them
pronounceable in a foreign one the
reason a Spaniard might tell you that he
is from Spain is because SP is just not
possible at the beginning of Spanish
words it's the same reason that when
English commentators talk about the
French footballer kylian mbappe they
often find themselves inserting a third
syllable to make it more pronounceable
it's because in English starting a word
with an m and a b next to each other is
just not done so people find themselves
subconsciously adapting words of a
foreign language to fit the rules of
Their Own
the next reason is stress no not that
kind it's where people put the emphasis
on words for example all French words
are stressed on the final syllables
usually with a higher pitch and greater
volume
that's why French speakers will call the
Texan City Houston instead of the
English Houston
meanwhile English words often have a
secondary stress in addition to the
primary one civilization for example
ditching your language's stress pattern
is often very hard and is not always
well taught
other elements of a language's rhythm
can be hard to pin down
Cantonese and Italian for example are
syllable time which means that every
syllable has roughly the same duration
if you repeat this sentence with every
syllable roughly equally timed you may
find yourself halfway through imitating
in Italian
whereas in English the stressed
syllables come at roughly regular
intervals and the remainder are less
distinctly pronounced
this is how you could distinguish
Italian from English being spoken
through a wall even if you can't make
out any individual words or sounds
if pronunciation stress and Rhythm were
better taught you might not find
yourself speaking like these next time
you go on holiday
[Music]